before we get started gonna give a
spoiler warning light spoiler warning
anyway probably a spoiler warning I just
don't know how to talk about some of the
things that kind of annoyed me in this
season without talking about the plot to
a degree that I didn't know going into
it I feel like that's part of the
experience it's not knowing you finding
it out as you're watching it's okay
spoiler warning I want to watch this
after you've seen season three or maybe
you don't care to in which case here you
go who cares
you didn't care anyway so now you get to
watch this review without a care in the
world I'll make sense so here we go
[Music]
all right I'm gonna warn you right now
this is pretty much I figured I am going
to review this season and it turned into
me bitching about this season for
however long this video is because the
season disappointed me so if you want to
see me gush about how great the season
is turn away now this is just gonna
disappoint the hell out of you if you
don't want to watch you don't have to
watch for the rest of you here for my
honest opinion here we go so story two
things season three is the third season
of stranger things this time it takes
place in summer fourth of July weekend
which I'll give them that they've
released the seasons poor what's going
on in the real world like season two
Halloween great we'll release it around
Halloween season three fourth of July
well we just got a delay until the
fourth of July respect basically that
big thing from the upside down they
called the mine flier and he's coming
after the crew now he's found a way to
manifest himself in our world in
physical form a lot happens in this
season I'm not saying like a lot happens
Lao is just jam-packed with great
thrills but it does have thrills for
sure I don't hate this season the
seasons fine but who walked away from
season one going it's fine like she's
the one was [ __ ] awesome now we get
to see the dreams it's fine it's such a
bummer but this is the weakest season
because this season there's no other way
to say it's invasion of the Body
Snatcher its invasion of the body
snatchers with a little bit of
terminator because that Russian dudes
come at that's the Terminator but that's
what the mind flayers doing it that's
the sport of the part I was talking
about he's possessing people is
possessing a bunch of people in this
town and it's invasion of the body
snatchers kind of he's not entirely in
its execution but it did remind me very
much of it and that's the first time in
stranger things I was actually like this
reminds me of something else like
stranger things always had throwbacks
for sure they always had that 80s
nostalgia but to its core it was a
really unique experience season 1 a boy
goes missing the small towns looking for
him can't find him because he's in the
upside down he's in this other dimension
a mom who looks crazy and her fortitude
figures it all out in her house
something they did again in season 2
instead of light she's like mapping out
the tunnel season 2 had redundancy from
season 1 yeah but it still felt season 2
was chapter tube of that whole story
this season 3
I mean it's chapter 3 sure but it was a
bit scatterbrained straight new things
season 3 for me felt like Pirates of the
Caribbean or the matrix or heroes worse
like that first chapter comes out
swinging and it's like oh my god that
was inspired it was great it was so much
fun but it was like hey we need more
stories from that world because people
loved the first one and you just see
contrast and quality between that first
chapter that first story that was good
because someone made that because they
wanted to tell a good story and the
sequels that were made because the first
one made money so now there's money to
be made stop with heroes
stop with the matrix start with pirates
now I'm saying it was stranger things I
just I've seen the cracks in the
stranger things armor and it bums me out
because it's celebration of nerd [ __ ] I
mean what's not to like now stranger
things is hitting sequel itis even take
Cary Elwes in this season he plays a
sleazy politician like they were like
well Matthew Modine was great in season
one we need another 80s actor to play
the bad guy in season two but it's like
he was playing a cartoon version of a
bad guy Matthew Modine say what you want
to say about him and Dark Knight Rises
and you're right to do so but in
stranger things he was still this very
imposing mysterious characters like who
is he where's it coming from and he was
part of the great mystery like who's a
little girl does she have psychic powers
of why she does have psychic powers
how'd she get those what is this why how
was it all tied together there's another
dimension oh my god I think Cary Elwes
is like yeah I'll play a cartoonish bad
guy even when this Russian guy is
roughing them up it doesn't feel scary
because Kari Ellis is still acting kind
of like a cartoons like even had a point
David Harbor and Winona Ryder started
feeling like some romance and some
rom-com or something but it felt so out
of place anytime they were doing stuff
on screen I was like let's get back to
the adventure I felt like they were
taking away from the adventure which is
a bummer cuz in season 1 they were
standouts I feel like they totally Homer
Simpson topper like I saw this starting
to happen in season 2 but season 3 he
goes full Homer Simpson well first like
a Homer Simpson was the working dad you
know he was the basic caricature sure
but caricature of an American working
dad then at a point Homer Simpson just
became an idiot now he's an idiot now
and I can't say now I haven't seen the
Simpsons in a while the last I remember
he went from schlubby dad to idiot I
served in season two now in season 3
hoppers just dumb he's not always dumb
granny he does have a few times where he
does become what he's supposed to be
which is pretty much small-town John
McClane if he was written by Stephen
King for a while in here I was like
hopper you're just done that mixed with
the redundant Ark of him and Winona
Ryder investigating the Russians which
is what some of the youth are already
doing in here a few times in here I
thought to myself it feels like they
don't know what to do with the
characters so they're just having them
do stuff like I like the cast is just
growing and now we have more because of
season 2 and we don't know what the
do with all of them and huh I don't know
we'll just throw darts at a dartboard
and decide their fate that way all right
they're investigating Russians I guess
they're investigating Russians too it
just makes them feel wasted here like
there's just bodies to be in the show
because they need to be in the show
contract says so like even at the end
they had to get this code and they end
up getting the code from what a Dustin's
friends I was there one thing that could
have contributed they didn't even do it
like I said were there to turn the keys
they need they needed warm bodies it's
like doing a raid in a game or something
it's like they're doing the Leviathan
raid and destiny to bear with me on this
in the Leviathan raid you need like four
people because you need bodies there to
do stuff to flip the switches and put
the little things in the posts so you
all can move on you can't solo that rate
they don't have to be good
they used need to be there to do [ __ ] I
feel like in the previous couple seasons
the upside down was like its own
character season one needs no
explanation for that seize it - like
when David Harbour goes into the pit and
then it all just turns upside down like
oh my god he crossed over somehow it's
intriguing stuff this one really the
upside down is it's a crack in a wall
with a laser going into it that's just
kind of all you really see of it get a
couple snaps of it a couple of images of
it but it didn't feel like its own
character anymore it's like it was a
character that was just lost and
forgotten yes a land a realm can be its
own character if it like stranger things
just kind of forgot that it's not like
this season was a complete wash it's
like by the end of this season was
actually very heartfelt it's like I'm
there tearing up going how am i tearing
up at the end of a mediocre season of TV
I don't know but I am oh god it was
great it was actually quite a beautiful
things like they put all their heart and
soul into the end of this season the
rest were like I don't know how we're
gonna get there just we'll get there
whatever seeing the neverending story
while you do they're gonna sing the
neverending story theme I have great
memories of that theme great memories of
my friends and I being shit-faced drunk
singing that in a kitchen ed we were 21
I think it doesn't matter there's a lot
of fun and I have great memories of it
cuz it's just a fun song to sing who
didn't go look it up on YouTube that
song on YouTube after the season was
done it totally did so did I it was in
the end stranger thing season 3 really
disappointed me season 3 just felt messy
to me just felt like a cartoon version
of stranger things some moments with the
villains didn't have any
that intensity were you like oh my gosh
this is really real right now I give
them props what they did with Billy
Billy was like one of those scary high
school bullies and season two there's no
way he was gonna hang out with our
beloved nerds in this season's how you
gonna bring them back they actually did
a neat thing bringing him back here
actually get some insight into him and I
really like that like this season had
moments of brilliance and moments of
conceptual brilliance like on paper I'm
sure the season sounded awesome
underneath this mall there's a
super-secret Russian base and they're
trying to crack into the upside down and
the mind flayers found a way to come
into the physical world and he's taken
control of the town he's gonna become a
big blood monster oh my god they got to
take him out like I'm sure it sounded
great but it's all about execution I
just didn't feel the execution land at
this time so the season does have
positive the positives being the concept
the tone has like a few good horror
moments in here couple of good character
moments I just felt the negatives vastly
did outweigh the positives in season
three one of the themes in here is
growing up because like when we first
met the kids they were really young and
they played D&D together but as kids age
to become teenagers they've become young
adults that dynamic kind of changes and
it's bittersweet it's kind of a bummer
to see because it's just it's real so
though it's kind of a bummer it's like
oh man I like saying this stuff because
it's not like the world because in the
world people grow up and it's the
immortal battle between people who are
cool was growing up and want to grow up
and people who want to keep things the
same I feel like in that I've really I
relate to will because I tend to be the
person's like ah I'm good without things
are why grow up let's play games let's
keep it going so I get props for that
being a huge theme in this season you're
more than that you need a cohesive story
and just kind of felt all over the place
from Anna I did alright so stranger
things season 3 have you seen it what do
you think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and if you
like this video if you can click that
like button it will help the video out
thus help the channel out thus help me
out and I very much appreciate that
click like if you love honest opinions
on the Internet
so thank you and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
you
[Music]